It's almost like an oxymoron.
You're in a dark, powerful suit and then you negated it by wearing a very soft, blue tie.
Now, which one of these two men do you think looks the most professional?
Which one looks like an expert?
Everybody's pointing over in the direction of this man.
So, white shirt and a striped tie is a nice combination for any Realtor...
...because the white shirt says, "I'm formal, I'm professional."
"I'm not going to be a slouch."
"I'm not going to let anybody down."
And the striped tie gives a certain friendliness.
And it gives a businesslike look also.
So, I advise that he give up sort of dusky-colored shirts.
Either wear a French blue shirt; a blue and white striped shirt is perfectly nice.